qu'on parque nacional financier étonnant
à couvrir alexis colère qui était
soupçonné vous savez de conflit
d'intérêts votre réaction
écoutez est-ce qu'il ya encore des
compatriotes qui pensent qu'il n'ya pas
d'ingérence entre la justice et la
sphère du pouvoir qui peut penser
aujourd'hui en france qui a une parfaite
indépendance de la justice
on a vu dans la sphère fillon le chef du
parquet national financier dénoncé une
ambiance avec d'énormes pressions avec
des instructions de madame champrenault
sa supérieure hiérarchique qui peut
penser un seul instant que cette affaire
a été traitée dans la sérénité
normalement qui peut penser que la
démocratie n'a pas été faussé et la
nouvelle ingérence président de la
république dans un dossier qui touche
quelqu'un qui lui est très très proches
je pense que la démocratie française va
mal il n'ya pas de séparation des
pouvoirs entre l'assemblée le législatif
et l'exécutif l'assemblée étant souvent
à la remorque pour ce qui concerne sa
majorité avec l'exécutif heureusement il
ya sénat quand même qui assure cette
indépendance
mais il ya aussi un problème entre
l'exécutif et la justice et c'est
préoccupant et dans cette hâte à ce
moment qu'est ce que vous demander la
réouverture du dossier une nouvelle
enquête de la police peut-être moi je
donne pas de leçons mais quand je
voudrais expliquer à vos spectateurs que
quand emmanuel macron dans cette
histoire qui a conduit françois fillon à
perdre dès le premier tour l'élection
présidentielle je constate qu'il a voulu
saisir le csm
le conseil supérieur des magistrats la
magistrature je veux simplement dire que
sur en 3 en 2015 2018 sur les 1000 48
plaintes adressées à ce csn simplement
deux ont été jugés recevables pour 0
sanction qui peut penser que demain le
csm aura une décision ou prononcera une
sanction personnes merci beaucoup bruno
retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je précise qu'à l'instant les
juges d'instruction annonce la reprise
des investigations donc dans la sphère
colère c'est à vous